man good that's my business
you've probably seen them before no
thanks
internal border checkpoint rookies now a
popular YouTube genre I don't want to
hold up traffic I want to freely travel
down the road may I do that summer funny
except you American citizen are you go
sittest are you Americanism yes sir
given I do need summer hostel and some
like the story we are about to tell you
result in weeks of jail time without a
single charge being frosted I was born
in 1984 and back then it was like Soviet
Union I moved to us I thought you know
I'm gonna get all my rights my freedoms
my Liberty you know American Dream reg
Rosenberg is a naturalized US citizen
who immigrated to America ten years ago
from Armenia memories and family stories
of Soviet rule in his country of origin
infused them with strong political
beliefs and a reverence for individual
rights today I see a lot of similarities
about this that stories that my parents
were telling me about the past if you
complained about the government back
then they were taking to Siberia see you
you don't have a right here to like to
legally challenge the government so
perhaps it's no surprise that Greg is a
checkpoint protester as a long-haul
trucker he has to drive through these
all the time after all there are about a
hundred seventy of them scattered across
the United States completely doesn't
make any sense to have these interior
checkpoints if they are saying they want
to protect you know the border it should
be on the border and not not inside the
America like violating our rights
freedom of movements keep in mind these
checkpoints aren't on an actual border
they just have to be within 100 miles of
one counting the northern border
southern border and the
coastlines the ACLU estimates that
roughly two-thirds of the nation's
population lives within this 100 mile
zone
Greg's ordeal began in the border town
of Laredo Texas he and his friend pulled
onto i-35 north at around midnight on
September 26 in a truck carrying a load
of Xerox machines destined for Fort
Worth but only 29 miles north of the
border they did encounter the Laredo
North Border Patrol station and Greg
would undergo a checkpoint interrogation
like he'd never experienced before the
immigration officer asked us if we are
US citizens
the driver my friend he was cooperate if
he was going to answer it but I started
to talk Greg says the Border Patrol took
his cell phone and tried to delete all
the footage of the encounter that he's
describing but he was able to use
software to recover the last two minutes
before his arrest I said to the
immigration officer excuse me but we
have a legal right not to answer your
question who ever liked to ask the
question I I would like not to answer
your question
so he went and he has the supervisor so
the supervisor came in he asked me to
pull over the truck to the secondary
lane and because there was no problem
because I refused to do so now this is
not the us listen okay I'm talking right
are you listening right and the
supervisor said hey if you don't move
the chart to the secondary Lane then I'm
gonna arrest you the US Supreme Court
the US did you read the class what they
did you read the Constitution
what was down they opened the door they
dragged me out it was like six of them
right after that video when they dragged
me out I was saying hey I'm not
resisting it cuz they were handcuffing
me and they were trying to hurt me I
didn't get it because I couldn't ever
imagine challenging government's actions
are talking about Constitution you know
about your rights that could get you
arrested this was only the beginning of
Greg's nightmare
Border Patrol detained and continued to
question Greg and his friend about their
citizenship at the station they were
able to verify that he was a citizen
using his ID but Greg says they wanted
something more basically was saying if I
agree that I'm wrong that I will never
do it again that I would apologize you
know give up my rights my values so I
would never come back again to the
checkpoints and but I couldn't do it all
so he's like when we look at you what do
we think why you from originally he's
like yeah you see after 9/11 that's why
we are doing
we asked Border Patrol emigration and
customs enforcement and the Southern
District of Texas a--'s u.s. attorney's
office to give their account of events
for this video they all refused most of
them they are they were just laughing
having fun of it you know they were
applauding the clapping their hands and
like making fun of the situation because
I was saying hey you can't just arrest
innocent people you know just because
they talk about the Constitution or they
want to exercise that right and it was
funny for them according to Gregg it was
after he declined to apologize for
inconveniencing the border agents the
station chief booked him for impeding
Border Patrol duties this offense fell
under a broad resisting assaulting or
impeding arrest statute a felon when I
first got arrested I asked to have a
lawyer I'm not gonna give a statement I
saw my lawyer after two weeks on October
10 a full nineteen days after Border
Patrol detained Gregg along i-35 the
government dropped its case and
dismissed all charges the problem here
is that the government drops charges
because there is no case against Gregg
because there is no evidence that he
resisted arrest because he didn't do
that
Prerna lau is an immigration attorney
representing gregg and a countersuit
against the government
the fact that he spent 19 days in jail
is a violation of his right as it's
false imprisonment that's that's
actually in a civil rights violation
there's a particularly important moment
in Gregg's video legally speaking
remember this you have a right to ask
the question hi I would like not to
answer your question
the agent says this Supreme Court case
United States versus Monsanto
the Supreme Court ruled that the Border
Patrol's routine stopping of the vehicle
at a permanent checkpoint located on a
major highway away from the Mexican
border for a brief questioning of the
vehicles occupants is consistent with
the Fourth Amendment but there's a catch
checkpoint searches are constitutional
only if justified by consent or probable
cause to search any further detention
must be based on consent or probable
cause they never stated any probable
cause or documented it and by simply
dismissing the charges and walking away
after a prison in Gregg for nineteen
days the government essentially punted
on the central legal question obviously
there's a conflict here whereby a CBP
can ask people about the citizenship
status but people don't have to answer
and that leads to a back-and-forth that
you may have seen beauty videos of
across the internet really well for
people most times people let go looking
around my vehicle I'm free to go I mean
I have my theories about a white bird
are differently I mean at least when I
was the video
greg's a US citizen but he's a
naturalized US citizen and he has an
accent if you I'm finishing right now
leaving my duties what do you like you
know it is a border and I believe it
played out this way because of racial
profiling they might be arresting me for
that in the beginning but they probably
would let me go if I just bought bow
down and you know because I said I'm a
libertarian I'm a principled person I
don't like government actions but I like
you guys I have no problem they hated me
for that so they arrested me what I
looked like but they press the charges
because of my minutes
back up right now we do not offer your
eyes usually back it up after young
children and I don't want them growing
up in a country where they can be just
arbitrarily seized by some random
government agent and presumed to be
guilty of something and then be forced
to you know just prove their innocence
on demand